[Applause]
[Music]
the sovath spider-verse coming back on
Monday I thought it'd be fun to take a
quick break away from the spider-verse
stories by getting into a discussion
about Galactus and the reason why I
chose Galactus here is because this is a
character who is very pivotal to the
Marvel continuity and to the existence
in Marvel Comics but as a character we
haven't really talked about that much we
even we've talked discuss stories
involving Galactus we've talked about
characters that are tied closely took a
lactis you know for example I guess the
Silver Surfer and in Franklin Richards
but we've never actually gotten into a
discussion about Galactus proper a so
Galactus first appeared in 1966 with
what many fans refer to as the Galactus
trilogy and of course Galactus was
created by Stan Lee and Jack Kirby and
in 2011 the comic book journal had
released an interview they had done with
Stan Lee where they had asked him about
about Galactus about why it is a
Galactus was created and what's and Lee
tells us here is that Galactus was
created because Marvel at the time when
Stan Lee and Jack Kirby were really kind
of the one-two punch during the Silver
Age we're looking towards characters and
villains that would break the standard
for what villains were at the time then
Marvel comics when you had the 1960s
when you had spider-man a fantastic for
Thor and so on despite the power of some
of these characters a lot of the
villains were still street-level thugs
there were still villains who for
whatever reason developed some measure
of abilities but their schemes were
always maybe I guess superficial they
always intended to somehow amass a great
amount of wealth or something like that
the villains would be defeated by the
superheroes they would be handed over to
the authorities and the villains will be
incarcerated the villains would then
break out of jail and the entire process
would start over again this was really a
timeless relationship between super
heroes and super villains dating all the
way back to the Golden Age and so Stan
Lee and Jack Kirby wanted to break this
standard and so they introduced the
concept of Galactus and a Stan Lee tells
us this character of Galactus has to be
somebody major he had to be a character
who was so powerful that he really
couldn't be stopped per se he could
simply just be staved off and so when he
introduced the idea to Jack Kirby Jack
Kirby had of course returned with the
depiction of Galactus that we had seen
in the original Galactus trilogy but he
had also introduced the Silver Surfer
and of course we'll get into this when
we get into the Herald's
of Galactus but with Galactus his
original introduction here what I'd like
you to take note of and cycle actus he
was very disconnected with regards to
his actions he doesn't really seem to
care about his effect on the planet
Earth about the fact that he's basically
killing the entire citizenry or I guess
the entire inhabitants of the planet
Earth to satiate his own appetite and
indeed this is the entire element for
the basis of the Silver Surfer turning
against Galactus in the original
Galactus trilogy and helping the
Fantastic Four defeat Galactus and this
would be a major focal point for the
character this will be a major part of
who he is and his personality going up
until we actually get into his
discussion with mistress of death and
the Fantastic Four issue number 257 but
before we get into that what we had
found was that Marvel had come along and
Thor issues number 168 and 169 and given
us the origin of Galactus but again was
really interesting here is that while
this was an origin that was perceived
and it was really the standard created
by Stan Lee and Jack Kirby in a 1996
Marvel had come back and they had
basically revamped this origin to a
degree that is to say they had basically
expanded on this a little bit more
information than the original Thor Thor
series in the original I guess origin
that was given to us and for what Marvel
had told us was that that he had existed
in the universe before the current is
earth-616 continuity and then at some
point along the line a plague began to
spread across that universe and as a
result it began killing off all forms of
sentient life Galan's entire role during
the course of his existence in this
continuity was to find a way to bring
this plague to an end but he was
unsuccessful and so when he had travel
back to the home planet basically
telling the scientists of his age that
defeat and that death was imminent they
decided the best way for them to meet
death was to meet it in a way that was
befitting of their culture and so what
they had done is they had simply flown
into a star and we're perceived to have
been killed and then in some former
fashioned Galactus had come into
existence in the current continuity now
what Marvel did again in 1996 is they
added a little more to the story to make
it make a little more sense because
again we were really kind of jumping
around with the origin that we saw in
Thor there were a lot of dots that were
connected we really didn't see how a got
to be all we knew is that it's somewhere
on the line the dots drew from one to
the other and so in this origin story
what Marvel does here is they keep the
entire concept of a plague but what they
say is that when Galan and his I guess
this handful of the members of his race
that we're still alive had flown into
this star while all the other members of
the race had been killed the sentience
of this galaxy had spoken directly with
Galactus and where did I guess with
Galan and what did it told Galan is that
the impending end of the universe is
coming there's no way to bring it to an
end but that the death of this universe
will give birth to a new one and so
what's going to happen is that this
sentience of this universe is going to
bond itself with Galan and they will be
born into the new universe as a singular
being and so when the new universe came
into existence Galactus was spit out and
he was spit out in the form of his ship
that he had previously taken or I guess
he had previously been occupying before
the universe came to an end now Marvel
doesn't really give us a timeframe here
in terms of when he had first gues been
spit out at the formation of the
universe and when he took on the form of
Galactus all they tell us is that
several millennia had passed and during
the time when he actually comes and is
revealed in the form of Galactus and the
time that he was spit out he had been
discovered or a ship a man discovered by
a watcher now this is not who watching
The Watcher this is simply just another
member of the Watchers race and what
this watcher realizes is that there
seems to be a vast amount of power
coming from the individual in the ship
and the way that he discovers that is
that he actually pulls the ship down to
his own planet and begins examining the
occupants inside now the possibility
existed that he could very well have
destroyed this version before it had I
guess usurped and and developed all
these different abilities but because of
the creed of the Watchers because the
Watchers exist is simply Chronicle and
never intervened
this watcher took no action and so as a
result the ship went back into its orbit
and it began traveling through the
cosmos once more now eventually this
ship comes across another planet and the
occupant sir I guess the natives of this
planet again don't really know what to
do they don't really know what to make
of this ship but what happens is they
simply leave the ship alone and during
this time the ship begins to take on a
different form it begins to actually
change itself into more of a cube and
during this time it really becomes an
incubation chamber for
lactis and what he does is he begins to
come to grips with his power he begins
to channel his energies he actually
develops the outfit that we see him wear
during his time in Marvel Comics that
allows him to regulate his energies more
or less and so ultimately as time
progresses again as millenia go by this
planet along with several others in this
portion of the galaxy engage in some
kind of a conflict and as a result the
invading forces see this cube of
Galactus and when they do they perceive
it to be some kind of a weapon and so
what they do is they attack this ship
and when they destroy Galactus emerges
now Galactus of course being that he's
been incubating all this time developing
his abilities has a vast amount of
hunger here and so what he does is he
destroys the invaders and then he
immediately begins consuming the planet
and this is the role that Galactus is
going to play for almost his entire
existence and the Marvel continuity as
far as as far as we know he's a
character that's constantly going to
travel around and consume other planets
and again this led directly up to the
Galactus trilogy when Galactus again not
really concerning himself with the
goings-on of the occupants of the
planets we consume those planets and
then move on to the next now what we
find in Fantastic Four issue number 257
in 1983 is that Marlowe was looking to
move forward model was looking to
introduce not just characters that again
were cosmic level threats like Galactus
but they wanted to expand on the nature
of characters in the sense of these
cosmic level beings having all different
manner of feelings all different manner
of emotions and so Marvel really
couldn't stay with this idea of Galactus
being a character who was so removed
from the ramifications of his actions
and so what we saw and the story is that
Galactus begins to appeal with mistress
death he begins to speak with mistress
death and what he tells us is that he
laments the idea he hates the idea of
travelling through the cosmos and wiping
out the the natives of various planets
in order to consume those planets but
mistress death thus wages this guilt
that he has by simply saying it's the
role that he was meant to play that
everybody has a role of a play that you
have characters like eternity which are
the embodiment of all that is you have a
you have infinity which is the
embodiment of all that will be you have
all these different characters of play
all these different concepts but that
all
regardless of the feelings that that
galactus has here that he's a character
that simply has to play this role and
what she's basically saying is that
galactus is a universal constant but she
doesn't really come out and say this
here it's actually not until Fantastic
Four issue number 262 that Marvel comes
out and says that Galactus is a
universal constant that this universe
has to have Galactus and in Fantastic
Four issue number 262 Marvel does this
by introducing an event called the trial
of Reed Richards and the reason why this
was done was because again Galactus who
had consumed other planets had a either
if I guess forced the occupants of those
planets to leave or had wiped out the
life on those planets entirely and so as
a result Reed Richards is brought before
the court of the Shiar Empire due to his
actions and really helping Galactus
stave off hunger on a couple different
situations and a couple different
scenarios here and so what they say is
that because Reed Richards have
basically helped Galactus stay alive
that any future planets that may be
destroyed here are due to the actions of
Reed Richards and so because Galactus is
guaranteed you can stick to continue
consuming planets Reed Richards is
responsible for all future actions to
take place effectively making Reed
Richards a I guess a contributor to
genocide here and so what happens as
various individuals are brought and
various races testify to the destruction
of their planet at the hands of Galactus
we see Odin for example stepping in and
saying that Reed Richards hadn't really
done anything wrong here that he was for
the most part maintaining the standard
that Galactus simply has to exist in the
universe for them Galactus is basically
a character who exists in the realm of a
God a character who simply just cannot
be stopped at a lot of other races out
there that exist in the mobile
continuity review Galactus that way and
what's really intriguing here is that
whenever a Galactus appears to erase
whenever he appears to another planet he
appears in a form of that betta that
race will recognize for example when he
appears to the Skrulls he appears as a
squirrel when he appears to the planet
Earth he appears as an earthling or ask
someone in Earth's form this is really
one of the cool elements of Galactus but
again it's actually not until towards
the end of the comic that eternity
appears and what eternity tells us here
is that again because Galactus is was
basically birthed into this universe
alongside
a multitude of other cosmic abstracts
that he has to exist that he can't not
exist that if the likest didn't exist
that he would more or less result in a
set of circumstances that would lead to
the ruin of all now again attorney
doesn't really say this per se what he
actually does is he takes the minds of
all these individuals who have existed
or who are currently present in this
courtroom and he merges them into one
single consciousness and then he reveals
to them the life that that galactus
leads here and so what they more or less
begin to do is they come to the
realization that Galactus has to a use
the city is a universal constant and so
what we do is we jump to the story of
Galactus and the devourer now this was
written by Lewis Simonson and this is
actually a very pivotal moment in the
realm of Marvel Comics and the reason
why is because after collages have been
established as a universal constant and
the trial of Reed Richards the question
that readers had was what would happen
if Galactus were killed what would
happen if he died if for some reason or
another he was removed from the
landscape of Marvel Comics what would be
the result and so during the Galactus
the Devourer storyline we ultimately saw
that the Silver Surfer had taken the
planet consuming equipment of Galactus
and turned it against Galactus the so
Galactus was effectively feeding on
himself
which resulted in Galactus starving to
death more or less as far as Galactus
could starve without a without a fresh
supply of energy and so as a result in a
fantastic four annual 2001 Marvel
introduced a villain named Abraxas and
the way they introduced this villain was
by simply saying that a practice was or
I guess is the embodiment of the
multiverses destruction he's really kind
of an idea more listened to taken
physical form but prior to the death of
Galactus Abraxas had been non-existent
he had simply just existed as a
non-existing entity and that makes any
sense but because the earth-616 version
of Galactus had ceased to exist because
he had starved to death this opened a
door that allowed Abraxas to actually
exist that allowed him to come into the
realm of existence and by virtue he
began hopping across the multiverse and
killing off every version of Galactus
that he could find and so what happens
is that this story actually jumps into
Fantastic Four issues number 400 and I'm
sorry 46 through 49 I think in volume 3
and put these stories and
with a story this is conclusion I guess
what we find is that Franklin Richards
again with an impressive display of
power is able to restore Galactus from
the earth-616 continuity back to life
who again had previously starved to
death and someone Galactus arrives he
confronts Abraxas and again a practice
really taunts Galactus here by saying
that that Arrakis has destroyed various
other versions of Galactus and this one
will be no different
but what Galactus says is that the
ultimate nullifier which has been
wielded by Abraxas in which of course is
capable of more or less resetting the
marvel universe of wiping out all life
is something that is very much a part of
Galactus himself in the sense of the to
go hand in hand and that Galactus had
created it and so what happens is
Galactus strips Abraxas of the ultimate
nullifier
but then is attacked by Frankie Rey by
his Herald Nova and so because of this
Galactus I guess the the ultimate
nullifier falls into the hands of Reed
Richards and what Reed Richards does is
he basically resets the universe prior
to the point when Abraxas first appeared
that is to say when when Silver Surfer
had killed Galactus and so as a result
Abraxas ceases to exist he simply just
not there anymore because Galactus had
never died and so what we do is again
Marvel goes behind our vil really
continues on with this concept of
Galactus continuing about his normal
business but what they also do in 2004
is they delve more into the Herald's of
Galactus because again a lot of people
were very curious about these these
different heralds we of course had seen
that after the Silver Surfer we had seen
Terrax we had seen Frankie Rey we saw
some characters like Dazzler who remain
into heralds but only for a temporary
time and so what Marvel did is during
the solo solo series of Thanos and
issues number 11 and number 12 they
introduced the character called the
Fallen and the Fallen was as far as
Marvel describes it the first Herald of
Galactus but he had been dismissed by
Galactus due to the insane nature of the
phone but also because he wouldn't carry
out the orders of Galactus and all that
really happens over the course of the
stories of the Fallen somehow manages to
escape his imprisonment confronts
Galactus but alongside the help of
Thanos is defeated and ultimately gets
eliminated entirely and so again what we
find is that as things progress as
things continue with Galactus Elias is
really kind of made a background
character here and there
my abraço i colitis has made a
background character in the Marvel
Comics is because again Marvel had been
branching out into all manner of
multiversal threats with the Infinity
Gauntlet storyline Marvel had basically
made it a common trend to have
multiversal contra constructs to have
other characters who were multiversal
threat that were as dangerous or more
dangerous than Galactus including
characters like like Franklin Richards
and so what we had seen was that this is
really all come to a head that Galactus
was really brought back to the
mainstream in the eyes of a lot of fans
as being such an intriguing character
during Jonathan Hickman's run of the
Fantastic Four with the Future
Foundation and what we had seen with
future foundation was that again with
going back to our discussion on Franklin
Richards
that there had been a Council of reeds
basically these different Reed Richards
from a multitude of different realities
but they had always they'd all joined
the Council of reeds and effectively
abandoned their families and abandoned
each version of their own family and so
as a result Reed Richards had refused to
take this role he had refused to abandon
his family but the mad Celestials which
were Celestials from an alternate
reality had followed Reed Richards to
the earth-616 continuity and again
weakened a little more discussion about
their it's a little more in-depth during
this with our discussion on Franklin
Richards which of course I'll have a
annotation on the screen for you to
check out but what happens is that
ultimately Reed Richards calls Galactus
from the earth-616 continuity to to the
planet Earth
and when Galactus arrives he confronts
the mad Celestials now the mad
Celestials are able to combine the three
of themselves into a singular being and
overpower and basically siphon all of
Galactus energies away which for all
intents and purposes kill Galactus or at
the very least leave him in a very
weakened state and so again Franklin
Richards from the future bonds his
energies with him yet with his younger
self and then makes Galactus his Herald
and this was a huge moment for a lot of
Marvel comic fans for Galactus fans and
the reason why is because we had never
ever ever seen an instance where
Galactus had been made The Herald of
someone else Galactus had always had his
own heralds he had always bestowed some
measure of the power cosmic on his own
heralds but he had never been made into
a herald by another being and so again
this really brought Galactus batch of
the mainstream who really made him a
four
I made him a front running character now
ultimately this was really a short-lived
popularity and the reason why was
because we had seen that's a result of
Wolverines actions in the age of Ultron
storyline that Galactus was sent or I
guess a ejected into the Ultimate
Universe by virtue of dimensional and
time displacement which of course picks
up with the entire Miles Morales
ultimate universe and the ultimate
ultimate stories but with Galactus he's
a character who in a lot of ways
embodies what it means to oppose a force
or to an - I guess encounter force that
is my unstoppable that is really only
held accountable by other beings who
don't really care about the goings-on of
earthbound characters and even Galactus
himself with his power is perceived by a
lot of earthbound characters as being
unstoppable in the sense that he wields
the power cosmic and so because he wills
the power cosmic there really isn't
anything that he can't do he's capable
of creating entire planets he can move
planets he can create life he can bestow
other people with the power cosmic
enhanced their abilities or give them
new abilities so really isn't anything
that he cannot do but the most part
Galactus is really kind of in in
no-man's land at the moment the best way
to describe it he's really kind of in a
position where again he's kind of
shuffled to a background character here
now whether or not this will change as
time progresses whether or not as we
move closer to Marvel's 2015 summer
event if we'll see him actually step
into the mainstream again and become a
forerunner is something we don't really
know all we know is that at this moment
Galactus is again continuing to be a
background character with that being
said we're gonna go ahead and bring this
video to an end I hope you guys enjoyed
it if you did let me know and I will
catch you guys later peace be sure to
follow me on Twitter there you can keep
up with all the updates from comics
explained and talk to me directly
[Music]